I think we're storing the tax rate to
the clinton-era rate is a good one maybe
go a little bit higher I'm worried about
going too much higher because I think
there is something to not so much the
disincentive effects i mean the classic
story that the conservatives like to
tell us if we tax people fifty percent
they wouldn't work I don't believe that
I just worry more that you create a lot
of incentives for gaming for tax
shelters so I don't mind that the
Clinton era top rate was thirty nine
point six percent on the highest income
people you could certainly knock that up
two three four percentage points I don't
think you've run into big problems but
if you pushed it too much higher I think
you would have problems I would want to
get rid of a lot of the unfairness and
tax code one of the things that jumps
out of me that President Obama actually
is addressing in his budget is this this
what i call the fund managers tax break
where if you run an equity fund or hedge
fund you pay taxes at the capital gains
tax rate rather than the normal income
tax rate that that allowed many of the
wealthiest people in the contrary to pay
a texture at fifteen percent as opposed
to you might have a firefighter pays the
tax rate twenty five percent that was
pretty unfair so i'd like to get rid of
that and actually along those lines I'd
actually like to see capital gains
income tax that the same rate as
ordinary income as well which was
actually a reagan here reform so that
wasn't that's not that radical notion in
1986 they they had capital gains income
tax at the same rate as normal income so
those would be some of my priorities the
last one that i think is a really good
way to raise money both since it raises
a lot of money and also raised in the
financial industry is is the modest tax
on financial transaction stock trades
sales of options futures if you had a
very modest tax england taxes stock
traded at quarter of one percent so if
you buy shares stock you pay a quarter
of one percent same when you sell it
they raised the equivalent relatively r
economy a 30 billion a year on that i
would apply to a broader instruments
that also have a ton options futures
credit default swaps the whole range
lower rates on those instruments but the
whole range of financial assets you can
easily raise over a hundred billion a
year that way and that that's attacks i
would have a minimal impact on people
are investing again they won't like the
tax than whatever likes to pay taxes but
no one who's looking to hold stock for
five or ten years is going to be that
affected by paying a quarter one percent
when they buy it and quarter one one
percent when they sell it but it will
have a very big impact on the people are
actively trading buying it two o'clock
selling
three o'clock and also the other big
impact will be on the financial industry
it will take a take a chunk out of the
height of the financial industry which
again I don't have a problem with it it
has grown too large this is a very good
way to rein it in and sort of the way I
think about it is that if you go to
gamble of Atlantic City you get taxed
you pay attacks about six percent on
your gambling not on your winning just
on your gambling we could do the same on
Wall Street
I take a couple points in immigration
first off we have to be clear what's
what's going on I mean we've had a
policy if people come over and work here
and that's been explicit policy even
though it again it violates the law and
the idea was that gave cheap cheaper
labor than you could have gotten by
hiring domestic workers and that's it
two effects obviously we have all these
people come in from low weight poor
countries work at lower wages and
secondly it does have an impact on the
less educated parsha of the workforce
and you know I know there's some
littered economic literature and that
finds mixed results but I'm inclined to
agree with those that do fine to have an
effect and just sort of at the face of
it when you talk about having more than
10 million workers come in competing
with you it's a little hard for me to
believe that doesn't have a downward
impact on your wages but anyhow what I
would say is we do want to give those
people full rights let them become
citizens if they choose let them
whatever have green card status whatever
we might do do that you know ensure that
they have the full rights of workers the
United States and enjoy you know be in a
position where they could push improve
their situation on the job improve their
living standards you are going to need
regulation of immigration going forward
which I think has to be done at the
employer level that they have to be
serious sanctions now the high end
workers we have in effect had employer
sanctions you don't have hospitals and
law firms and universities just bringing
in huge numbers of immigrants and
undercutting their their existing
workforce that's actually against the
law and no one really tries that because
I think if they did do that they would
crack they would be crackdown on so you
don't get Walmart university or Walmart
hospital bringing in a huge number of
professionals from India or some other
country and I think that's actually
unfortunate because I think would
benefit the developing countries benefit
the United States to allow a more free
flow of highly skilled immigrants and it
would benefit us because we would get
its exact same argument we make about
trade except it would be at the high end
rather than low end we would get these
services medical services legal services
on down the list at much lower prices if
we allowed people from developing
countries are willing to work for lower
wages because their wages in their home
country are so low that would still be a
big jump up if they work for two-thirds
the wages that our professionals
received so we would get a huge benefit
that way those workers themselves it
hugely benefits since they would see
huge increase in living standards
we can structure it so that the
countries benefit so we in effect have
some sort of tax associated with
basically we paying for their training
costs in India and China or whatever
country it might be so that they might
be able to educate two or three doctors
for every doctor that came to work in
the United States so think we could
structure this in a way condoms like to
talk about trade as being a win-win it's
often not that way you have a lot of
losers in that story we could structure
this in a way that actually is a win-win
where people the United States would
gain the immigrants coming to work here
would gain and the home countries again
as well if we ensure that a portion of
those wages were in effect repatriated
back to the home countries to educate
more workers
it's it's interesting I assume you're
referring to the bankruptcy reform from
past a few years ago it's kind of
striking that because now one of the
issues that's been hotly debated in
Congress is an effort to change
bankruptcy law so that people who go
into bankruptcy could have the terms
their mortgages reissued because right
now mortgages enjoy privileged status
that that that contract alone cannot be
reworded by a bankruptcy judge so they
could write down credit card debt car
loan debt any other form of debt but
residential mortgages cannot be
rewritten and one of the arguments that
the industry the banking industry is
trotted out as they've talked about the
sanctity of contract that we don't want
to create uncertainty no back a few
years ago they changed the bankruptcy
law to make it much harder for people to
declare bankruptcy and their then they
actually did reword contracts so you
could have borrowed money under the old
bankruptcy regime where it was I won't
say easy but at least much easier to go
into court and have your debts and old
and then they change the terms of the
contract on you so it became much much
harder so it's kind of striking this
sort of inconsistency but I would argue
that in general you do want people when
they're in over their heads to be able
to go into bankruptcy and you know
alleviate much if not all their debt two
reasons one is as a moral issue that
typically people who we know we've dad
on this most the people who end up the
bankruptcy it's not they were spent
thrust they've lost their job there's a
family breakup there's a health problem
that accounts for the overwhelming
majority of cases so really was people
come falling in bad straits the second
as an economic consideration what we're
saying if we have sort of punitive
banquet of punitive bankruptcy law that
we really i would say have now we're in
effect imposing large taxes revering the
government chase after people to an
effect tax their income often a very
high rates and all these people complain
about taxes well it's the exact same
thing if you're in effect having your
wages tax tree pay old debts so rather
than having the government chase after
people to force them you know five ten
fifteen twenty years i'll pay debts that
they incurred maybe when they're very
young i think it makes much more sense
to say okay if you end up in bad straits
you don't you're not going to have to
repay the debts and let's flip this over
no one gets into debt like that unless
someone lent them money so what this
means is that there
a bad decision on the part of the lender
they judge credit risk poorly and again
thinking from a free market standpoint
if you judge credit risk poorly well
then maybe you're not a good business
person maybe you shouldn't be in
business so in effect what we said with
the change in the bankruptcy law we were
rewarding bad business practices you had
a lot of businesses that had made loans
to people couldn't afford to pay them
back and rather than telling those
businesses well next time be more
careful who you lend money to we said oh
we're going to help you pick get that
money back and I think that was
absolutely the wrong way to go
well I take a very mixed stance on small
business I mean I think we want people
to be able to start businesses want to
create opportunities for them make sure
that you have a level playing field but
I think many ways we've gone overboard
there's all sorts of provisions in the
tax code on various regulations that
have exemptions for small businesses
special loans that are available to
small businesses that amount to very
large subsidies and you have to ask
yourself how much money do we want to
give someone just because they're
opening up a business I mean instead I
want to say well that's an option you
know that's a reasonable thing for you
to do but should taxpayers should an
ordinary worker should someone who's
working at a clothing store should they
have to pay more money in taxes because
someone across the street from them
opened up a business which might will go
under I mean a lot of people open
businesses and it's a bad choice for
them a lot of people most small
businesses fail and they understand
people want to give it a try and
everything but we're not necessarily
doing them a favor to say take all your
life savings borrow it to the hilt and
then you know struggle for three years
and end up with nothing we're not
necessarily doing them a favor so I just
say we need clearer eyes on this and
some of the practices I mentioned the
book we exempt businesses small
businesses from safety regulation so I
was particularly struck by this with
mining that if you you're you're a mine
owner and you had your below a certain
size you're not subject to safety
regulation well I'm no more anxious to
see a mine or die in the small mind and
a large mine I mean it just doesn't make
any sense to me so you have to look at
this I think with clear eyes so we do
want people to have opportunities to
open small businesses I think it's good
idea to have special loan facilities
sure they have adequate access to
capital when we award government
contracts make sure that they're
accessible to small businesses there's
all sorts of things that we we do we
should do more of that I think are very
reasonable in terms of allowing a level
playing field between larger and smaller
businesses but on the other hand I think
we often have gone overboard it doesn't
make sense to tax people to give money
to someone just because they've opened a
small business that that's not that's
not a badge of honor I mean they did I
don't think anyone should pay higher
taxes just because their neighbor opened
a small business
well it's only threatened politically
there's a lot of people who want to cut
it back but in terms of the viability of
the program itself we don't have the
latest projections new projections Isis
a post-crash projections from the
Congressional Budget Office but their
projections that they put out last
summer showed the program could pay all
benefits through the year two thousand
forty nine with no changes whatsoever
and even if we never did anything it
could still pay about 75% of projected
benefits which would be higher than what
retires are getting today so what that
would mean is if we just put the thing
on autopilot never paid any attention to
it at all 2060 2070 2080 retirees in
those years would be getting
considerably more money than retirees do
today so this idea that there's some
huge problem that's simply not sure
there's a long-range problem that stems
from the fact we're projected to live
longer which hopefully will be true so
you know somewhere down the road we'll
have to make adjustments and that can
take the form that we might raise taxes
some at some point in the future might
decide to raise retirement ages you know
even maybe people have to work a little
longer to their life but that's a
distant problem it's very distant
different from the way it's being
portrayed that here's this program
that's about to go bankrupt and it's
particularly pernicious that people are
talking about doing something to it now
because the people the workers and their
their 40s their 50s even 60s are about
to retire they just seen everything they
work for disappear if they had equity in
their home lunch that equities just
disappeared they had put money in a 401k
most people of course haven't put very
much in 401 k retirement plan but let's
say they had they just lost thirty forty
percent of that so the idea that you
would take money away from these people
at the edge of retirement have just lost
trillions of dollars the loss to older
workers are entire eases on the order of
15 trillion dollars that we would look
to take away the Social Security from
them that's really pernicious and you
know it's it's remarkable to me that you
have so many politicians that are
willing to get up there and say that
actually I shouldn't say that because i
usually don't put in those terms but
that is what they were trying to do so
it paces a very real political threat
remarkably the biggest threat is from
the people brought on this disaster i
mean i look at peter peterson is
certainly a big advocate kind social
security benefits here's a man worked on
Wall Street got very rich working on
Wall Street and he's using much of the
money that he
earned to try to undermine social
security so that other people can't
enjoy a decent retirement so it's it's
incredibly pernicious that both this
effort to take away the money from
people worked for this they paid in for
those benefits we're not giving them a
gift they paid for them they pay taxes
for them and secondly that the people
are leading the charge are exactly the
same people who brought on this economic
disaster